joining us now chief secretary to the
treasury um in the studio as you can see
and that's simon clark hi good morning
thanks for joining us what's the
government going to do about it well we
hope very much that uh ongoing talks
between the employer and the the unions
will make
progress today and clearly
from our point of view we want to see a
resolution to uh to this issue but we
obviously want to see a resolution that
works for everybody and that needs to
work for real workers but critically it
needs to work for passengers and the
taxpayer as well and that's what
underpins this whole process we need a
railway which is both sustainable in
terms of its costs but also in terms of
the service it provides to the public
and at the moment we don't have that the
the taxpayer supported the railway
industry very substantially during the
pandemic we're now coming out of that we
need the railway to be as i say a
sustainable uh force in our country it
isn't those changes need to be secured
as part of this wider negotiation so
what are you going to do to stop the
strike well as i say we continue to uh
to make sure that those talks uh have
the support from government that they
need
but ultimately this is a matter between
the employers uh the train operating
companies and network rail and the trade
unions and the government doesn't sit uh
directly as a part of those talks for a
very good reason that you know we don't
intervene in the specific process
between an employer and the unions
representing employees but we are there
to provide
uh the support uh and the enabling
framework for those talks to succeed
but if you don't get involved the
country's going to grind to a halt for a
week well ultimately okay we don't we we
we don't uh control all the levers that
need to be uh the that need to be held
here as the the employer the employer is
network rail and the train operating
companies they are the ones who need to
drive the program of reform to make the
railway sustainable we we don't own the
railways uh ourselves and it wouldn't be
right for us to substitute ourselves for
the role of the employer we recognize
these strikes are a huge inconvenience
for millions of people i absolutely want
them not to go ahead but it isn't the
case that we can put ourselves into the
hot seat in place of the legal employer
no you say you're not getting involved
with the negotiations but then you say
something like this at the weekend what
we can't do is have unrealistic
expectations around pay which do in turn
prolong and intensify this inflation
problem because we all want it to end
and the way it will end soonest is if we
are sensible about pay so you are
getting involved well that uh that my
comments there were in the context of
the wider public sector pay uh review
bodies process which is taking uh taking
place at the moment which will determine
pay for the people who the government
does employ directly that is to say
uh our teachers our nurses our police
doesn't apply to the right well it sets
it sets an overall framework which is
important for employers to understand
which is that obviously public sector
pay discipline really matters here we
have an inflation problem in this
country as indeed is common across the
western world after the pandemic if we
don't want that problem to either
intensify or prolong itself then we need
to be sensible around pay awards if we
give awards which are uh above inflation
in this landscape then we are in a
really difficult place in terms of
bringing down inflation which in turn
obviously in turn obviously is driving
the cost of living but that's not what
the rmt is asking for they're asking for
7.1 percent and inflation looks so it'll
be riding at something like 11 well the
the issue the issue we need to secure
for the railways is about making sure
that you have a sustainable offer on pay
but also linked to productivity reform
as well because the railways are are not
run as efficiently as they could be
there are all sorts of practices there
which are seriously outdated which
uh which make the railways bit more
expensive to operate but also less
efficient in terms of their operation
than they otherwise ought to be and so
there's a variety of a variety of things
that need to change whether that be in
ticket offices or in terms of
maintenance or in terms of
different different unions not really
offering the smoothest possible service
when it comes to
how they how they operate which do need
to which do need to change if the
taxpayer and the fair payer is to get
the the right deal so it's the right
idea then to um for effectively rail
workers to suffer a pay cut well in the
current situation
with with inflation which is a which is
which is a real issue we do have to be
very very sensitive if we start having
pay awards which take us uh close to
double digits then we are going to see
this problem prolonged and that is that
is just the economic reality of where we
find ourselves at at the moment and is
that a yes then well
i'm not i'm not as i say i i'm not the
the legal employer uh in in in in this
dispute and so i'm not going to
substitute myself for network rail for
the train operating companies but we do
absolutely need to have an understanding
across the wider public sector that we
cannot have inflation busting pay
increases because that will in turn
drive the problem we're trying to solve
how likely do you think it is that
strengths will go ahead
i fear it is uh likely that they will go
ahead uh clearly we will continue to
support the negotiations until such time
as there's there's no more uh time to
discuss but i think the public do this
week need to be where there will be very
substantial uh disruption and it is
therefore sensible to make preparations
for that now you um want to tell us a
little bit about a cost of living
calculator which will reflect the
national insurance um and and how people
will be saving money or otherwise but at
the weekend we saw thousands of people
coming to central london to demonstrate
about the cost of living crisis is this
government tone deaf when it comes to
what's happening no absolutely not i
mean we we we are very confident that
the 37 billion pounds package of support
that we've put in place much of which of
course is yet to kick in because it will
be paid into people's bank accounts
throughout the course of the summer and
the autumn ahead will very substantially
help with the cost of living pressures
that families are facing that's worth
1 200 pounds for roughly one in three uk
homes for most families it's worth at
least 550 pounds this year it is
something which is there to help people
look the trade the trade union movement
uh you know who are not uh it must be
said normally massive supporters of
conservative governments will we'll take
certainly not but it is fair to say that
i don't think this can be taken as a
snapshot of of mainstream britain this
is this is the the tuc on a march that
is a very different uh group of people
to the wider public we all recognize
that there are there are real challenges
at the moment but it is this government
working to try and make sure that we
come out of the pandemic that we grow
the economy and that we manage the
public finances responsibly but the tuc
is representing lots of trade union
members of course and it does look as
though from reading the papers this
morning that more and more of those
trade unions will be balloting their
members to go on strike it looks as
though we are heading towards a summer
of discontent well look we have to see
what happens with the individual unions
what i'd emphasize is there is a pay
review body process that's in place
across government that's uh independent
of government so there are there are
independent groups of experts who
recommend pay awards and it's then for
individual government departments to
respond to those for the workforce is
concerned but those those uh bodies are
reporting throughout the course of june
and then government departments will set
up their response in due course
from what i understand and it is early
days those rewards are coming those
awards are coming in at a sensible uh
level which is great it does mean that
there will be
good pay offers i think on the table for
public sector workforces it's important
that we wait and see what those uh
awards are when and then and then
obviously it will be for individual
workforces and the trade unions to
respond but i do think people have to
recognize if we're going to
you know forestall the evil of inflation
inflation destroys savings it destroys
growth it damages any economy where it
gets the endemic grip then we are going
to have to show uh collective
society-wide responsibility and i think
i think that's a message which people
watching this program will understand
for people who are struggling to make
ends meet as it is and they look as
though they are realistically going to
have a pay cut given what's happening
with inflation so they are going to
exercise their democratic right
potentially to go on strike and as a
result you may well find yourselves
with a summary of discontent well we'll
cross uh that's a possibility no what i
would say is
i recognize that there is sacrifice
involved in this situation we've put in
place a 37 billion pound package of
support to help to help address it i'm
not going to preempt what the results of
individual pay review body processes
will be or how the trade unions will
respond
as i said all i can do is emphasize the
government is trying in good faith to
manage what is a very difficult
balancing act between making sure that
people get the pay awards that they
deserve and our public sector workers
genuinely do do the most fantastic job
but this has to be set against the wider
responsibility i have the government has
to the public finances to make sure they
are sustainable we're spending 83
billion pounds this year on our debt
interest payments after covid we cannot
afford to get into a situation where we
lose control of the public finances and
in turn all suffer unions are
disagreement aren't they and they're
saying you know we're going to ballot
our members unless we get a reality
you know with great respect to the trade
union leaders they obviously don't come
at this from a point of view of a
conservative government we we have a
mandate from the british public to to
manage
the national finances sensibly that's
always in the end what a conservative
government is there to do
it is vitally important that as we come
out of this incredibly difficult
situation where we are facing the twin
headwinds of what's happened with covid
and now of course war in europe that we
that we do strike the right balance here
and when you're talking about public
sector pay are you suggesting given that
you're suggesting that potentially there
would be reasonable payoff as they will
match inflation i i'm not i'm not going
to preempt the results of the individual
pay review bodies but i think i think i
think it is unlikely that they will they
will match the headline rate of
inflation at the rates we're now seeing
but that is precisely the point i'm
making that if we try and match or
exceed inflation if we end up in a cycle
where everyone starts targeting uh the
levels that we're seeing now nine ten
percent that is going to be totally
unsustainable workers have to prepare
for a pay cut well i think the private
sector the private sector as well will
go through this okay i think i think the
point is very very few people are going
to be getting uh pay offers which which
are in double figures i think it would
be highly uh unsustainable if they were
to do so um talk to me about airport
chaos because it is absolutely chaotic
at the moment at many of our airports is
brexit to blame
no i think what we're seeing here is the
result of the airline industry having
obviously massively contracted during
the pandemic and now it's facing this
surge of pent-up demand as things stand
back up and uh truth be told it isn't uh
resourced and manned for that challenge
that's why i think it is sensible that
what we're starting to see now is some
of the airports revising their schedules
for the summer season ahead because
frankly we can't have a repeat of the
scenes that we've been having at some of
our airports over recent uh recent weeks
and i know the transport secretary
ministers there have been working very
closely with the airline industry to try
and get into a more sensible place
because they are at the moment offering
flights they simply can't honor and that
is that is terrible for passengers
completely mental at some of these
airports at the moment um i mean the
chief exec of ryanair says uh is blaming
the chaos on inflexible post-brexit
labor market and the ceo of wizair
sayings the uk's post-brexit immigration
policy is putting a lot of strain on the
labor market so they say it's brexit
well
i mean ultimately i think the british
people made their views very clear on uh
you know unlimited immigration from the
eu uh and and there were very good
reasons why we we voted to have a
controlled immigration policy
this but i but i do not i do not accept
that this is this is simply a direct
pasture effect from brexit what i would
say is this is a result of an industry
which massively slimmed down and
understandably so at a time when uh
flying was well-known possible for a
year and a half two years it's now
massively expanded its operations and
the pressure is enormous and it hasn't
managed to align the two
we will do our part as government to try
and make sure that our side of things is
right from issues like passports to
border control
while we're pouring resource into this
we're making sure that the whole
processes are as robust as they can be
but in turn the airlines
the airlines but the airlines need to do
their part of our part of things and
that make sure that the flights that
they're actually offering can indeed be
honored and that's that's the key thing
what does pouring resource mean well it
means that we're making sure that all of
these departments whether that be
uh the border force or or past or the
passport office have the resources they
need to manage this and as part of the
spending review we conducted last
october we we obviously made sure that
all of our home office infrastructure
has the funding it needs uh to do the
job what do you want to say to people
who are waiting at home who could be one
of those 500 000 people that are waiting
for their passports well we all
recognize the frustrations that go uh
that go with waiting for a passport and
the pressure that comes if there's a
holiday imminent what i can say is that
the government is working flat out to
make sure that people get those in a
timely fashion and as i understand it
the the the waiting times are coming
down which is really positive uh and and
that's something we'll continue to
prioritize we're out of time sadly it's
good to talk to you thank you thank you
for joining us thank you as always